Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. Welcome back to those of you who've listened to the first of these two podcasts that we're doing to mark the death of Queen Elizabeth II and the accession of King Charles III. So, Tom, we ended the last episode, you talking about um the queen's anointing at her coronation in 1953 and uh her sense of dare i say it as her sacral queenship um and i i guess for the first certainly the first few years the first sort of half decade decade or so, everything is actually pretty smooth, isn't it?
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家播客节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听特权，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎收听《历史其余部分》。欢迎各位再次收听这两期播客中的第一期，我们录制这两期节目是为了纪念伊丽莎白二世女王的逝世以及查理三世国王的登基。所以，汤姆，上一集节目结束时，你谈到了嗯1953年女王加冕典礼上的涂油礼，以及她对——恕我直言——她那种圣洁女王身份的感知，而且我想，在最初的几年里，至少是最初的半个十年或十年左右，一切其实都相当顺利，对吧？
For the queen sort of domestically. But of course, the paradox is that at home, her reign seems entirely untroubled. But abroad, the context is changing so quickly. You know, she becomes queen of an empire. But within a decade or so, that empire is largely defunct, isn't it? Yeah. but within a decade or so that empire is largely defunct isn't it yeah and she she um i mean i think she plays i don't know an important role but she certainly plays a facilitating role doesn't she in the process of decolonization she is i mean she's certainly not battling to save the empire and yeah and often i mean she so when harold mcmillan uh gives his his speech in south africa
对女王在内部事务上来说。但当然，矛盾之处在于，在国内容，她的统治似乎完全没有受到困扰。但在海外，背景变化得太快了。你知道，她成为了一个帝国的女王。但在大约十年左右的时间里，那个帝国基本上就名存实亡了，不是吗？是的。但在大约十年左右的时间里，那个帝国基本上就名存实亡了，不是吗？是的，而且她，她——我的意思是，我认为她扮演了一个，我不知道算是一个重要的角色，但她在去殖民化的过程中绝对扮演了一个促进者的角色，不是吗？她——我的意思是，她绝对不是在为拯救帝国而战，对吧？而且通常，我的意思是，所以当哈罗德·麦克米伦在南非发表
about the winds of change blowing and all that kind of thing, she writes to him and says, what a wonderful speech. I approve of it. And it's not like she is going around desperately trying to was Queen of Sri Lanka. I mean, it's kind of amazing to think that. But the great object of her love becomes the Commonwealth, which is essentially quite a neat shimmy. So what had been the empire becomes first the British Commonwealth and then the Commonwealth, in which Britain has no kind of primal role. And the Queen's evident devotion to the Commonwealth and to all the countries of the Commonwealth kind of enables even countries that have been kind of emerged from colonial wars, from kind of resistance movements to British rule, to actually say, it's a kind of halfway house. We won't have the Queen as head of state, but we will stay in the Commonwealth and the Queen will be the head of the Commonwealth. And so it's a brilliant trick,
关于变革之风吹拂诸如此类言论的演讲时，她写信给他，说这是一场多么精彩的演讲。我赞同。这可不是说她四处奔走、拼命试图去当斯里兰卡女王。我的意思是，想到这一点真是令人惊叹。但她热爱的大业变成了英联邦，这本质上是一个相当巧妙的转身。因此，曾经的帝国先是变成了英联邦（British Commonwealth），然后变成了英联邦（Commonwealth），在这个组织中，英国没有任何那种至高无上的核心角色。女王对英联邦以及所有英联邦国家的明显热爱，使得甚至那些从殖民统治的战争和反抗运动中走出来的国家也能够表示，这是一个类似中间站的安排。我们不会让女王担任国家元首，但我们会留在英联邦，而女王将担任英联邦元首。所以这是一个绝妙的把戏，
I think. And the degree to which it was kind of consciously designed by the Queen, I don't know, but I think it was kind of quite effective. But Dominic, what I would also ask you is, does this create a tension between her role, say, in Britain and her overseas roles? But we should kind of focus, shouldn't we, on the fact that she is not just the Queen of the United Kingdom. So she's the head of the Commonwealth. She is Queen of kind of various overseas territories that Britain still holds, so Falklands, Gibraltar, that kind of thing. She's Queen of the Crown Dependency, so famously as she's the Duke of Normandy in the Channel Islands.
我认为。至于这种做法在多大程度上是女王有意识设计的，我不得而知，但我认为它相当有效。不过，多米尼克，我还要问你的是，这是否会在她在英国的角色和她在海外的角色之间产生某种张力呢？但我们应该把重点放在她不仅是大不列颠及北爱尔兰联合王国女王这一事实上，不是吗？所以她是英联邦元首。她是英国目前依然控制的各种海外领地的女王，比如福克兰群岛、直布罗陀诸如此类的地方。她是王权属地（Crown Dependency）的女王，最著名的就是她是海峡群岛的诺曼底公爵。
And then she's Queen of what? Is it 16 independent nations, I think? She's Queen of Australia. She's Queen of Canada. She's Queen of New Zealand. Exactly. And Queen of those things in her own right, as it were, not as a function of being Queen of the United Kingdom.
然后她是什么的女王？我想是16个独立国家的女王？她是澳大利亚女王。她是加拿大女王。她是新西兰女王。没错。而且是以她自己的名义成为这些国家的女王，而不是作为英国女王的附属职能，可以说是这样。
Exactly. Exactly. And so she's head of state of about a seventh of the Earth's surface, which is by miles more than any other head of state. So is there a tension there yeah i mean i don't think to begin with that that tension is evident so she goes to australia and she's they're saying what 75 i think on the news yesterday on her first tour went out to see her yeah three quarters of the australian population turned out to see her an extraordinary statistic
没错。完全没错。所以她是地球表面大约七分之一的国家元首，这远远超过了任何其他的国家元首。那么，这其中是否存在张力呢？是的，我的意思是，我认为一开始这种张力并不明显。所以她去澳大利亚，昨天新闻上说，在澳大利亚，我想大约有75%的人在她的第一次访问时都出来看她了？是的，四分之三的澳大利亚人口都出来看她了，这是一个非同寻常的数据。
and she she is devoted. I mean, she's devoted to Australia, to New Zealand, to Canada, I think, especially. She goes to Canada. She's visited Canada more than any other country. And so she clearly feels very, very, you know, the coronation oath that she swore in Westminster Abbey applies equally to all those countries as well. And she is committed and dutiful to it.
而且她，她是全心投入的。我的意思是，她对澳大利亚、新西兰、特别是加拿大充满热忱。她去了加拿大。她访问加拿大的次数比其他任何国家都多。因此，她显然感到非常非常，你知道的，她在威斯敏斯特大教堂宣誓的加冕誓言同样适用于所有这些国家，她对此承担着责任并尽职尽责。
But is there a tension between that role that she has as a queen of the world, queen of the Commonwealth, queen of all these other countries and her role as queen of the United Kingdom? Yes, I think is the short answer, but it doesn't become apparent until later on. So at the beginning, just to go back to something you were saying a second ago, I completely agree with you that the queen plays, I mean, it's obviously not a leading part, but she definitely doesn't play no part in decolonization. So in other words, she does play a small supporting role. And I think the importance there is we were talking the first um podcast about the sense of the queen being in a prison and the sense of whether you have choices she does have a choice she and her court could unquestionably have put themselves in the late 1950s and early 1960s
但是，她在作为世界女王、英联邦女王、所有这些其他国家的女王这一角色，与她作为英国女王的角色之间，是否存在某种张力呢？是的，简而言之我认为是有的，但直到后来它才变得明显起来。所以一开始，回到你刚才说的话，我完全同意你的看法，即女王扮演的角色——我的意思是，这显然不是主导角色，但她在去殖民化中绝对不是无所作为。换句话说，她确实扮演了一个小型配角。我认为重要的地方在于，我们在第一期播客中谈到了女王感觉身处监狱的感觉，以及你是否拥有选择权的感受——她确实有选择。她和她的宫廷在20世纪50年代末和60年代初，毫无疑问地完全可以将自己置于
on the on the side of deep entrenched conservatism. Because her father and grandfather were both overtly Tory, right? Yeah, agreed. Yeah. Yeah. Well, actually, you know what? They are. But one of the brilliance actually of George V, her grandfather was an operator,
坚定根深蒂固的保守主义一边。因为她的父亲和祖父显然都是坚定的保守党人，对吧？是的，同意。没错。嗯，事实上，你知道吗？他们确实是。但乔治五世（她的祖父）真正的高明之处在于，他是一个极其精明的政治运作高手，
is that he had accommodated himself very, very successfully to having a Labour government. He had, in fact, got on extremely well with his Labour ministers. But no one ever doubted that he was a kind of Tory country squire at heart. In many ways, certainly culturally, he's very reactionary, but he's intelligent and flexible enough to adjust to the new reality. But in the 1950s and 1960s, there are people, I think Lord Salisbury, for example, within the Conservative Party
那就是他非常非常成功地适应了工党政府的存在。事实上，他和他的工党大臣们相处得极其融洽。但从来没有人怀疑他内心深处是一位保守党的乡村乡绅。在许多方面，肯定在文化上，他非常保守，但他足够聪明和灵活，能够适应新的现实。但在20世纪50年代和60年代，保守党内部确实有人，比如索尔兹伯里勋爵（Lord Salisbury），
who are critical of Macmillan's government, who say they're scuttling to get out of all these places. The empire is being dismantled before our very eyes. She could, and she and Philip could, by gestures, by hints, by selective leaks, all these kinds of things have made clear their dissatisfaction with what Macmillan is doing. But quite the reverse. I mean, the most famous example, which people who, we talked about the crown in the first episode, people who've seen the crown will undoubtedly remember this, that in 1961, she goes to Ghana and she dances with Kwame Nkrumah, the president,
他们对麦克米伦政府持批评态度，认为他们在狼狈逃离所有这些地方。帝国正在我们眼前分崩离析。她本可以，她和菲利普本可以通过姿态、暗示、有选择性的泄密等各种方式，明确表示他们对麦克米伦所作所为的不满。但事实恰恰相反。我的意思是，最著名的例子是——我们在第一期节目中谈到过王室，看过《王冠》的人毫无疑问会记得这一点——1961年，她访问了加纳，并与总统夸梅·恩克鲁玛（Kwame Nkrumah）共舞，
who was at the time one of the absolute iconic standard bearers of anti-colonialism, of criticism of the Western empires and so on and so forth. And indeed, in South Africa, as we were saying, the apartheid government is shocked. One newspaper says how horrible it is to see the honored head of the once mighty British empire dancing with the black natives of pagan Africa. I mean, that's an extraordinary thing, I think. Her palpable enthusiasm, her love of Africa, it's clearly not contrived and feigned. I mean, you can see from the clips that this isn't a sort of a smile painfully worn and the fact she's bored out of her mind. She hates it.
他当时是反殖民主义、批评西方帝国等各种思潮的绝对标志性旗手之一。事实上，正如我们所说，在南非，种族隔离政府感到震惊。一家报纸说，看到曾经强大无比的大英帝国的受人尊敬的元首与野蛮非洲的黑人土著跳舞，是多么可怕的一件事。我的意思是，我认为这是一件非同寻常的事。她那显而易见的热情，她对非洲的热爱，显然不是刻意伪装出来的。我的意思是，你可以从片段中看出，这不是那种痛苦挤出的微笑，也不是那种她无聊透顶的表现。她讨厌那种假装。
She genuinely enjoys it. She takes the Commonwealth very seriously. And I think, as you say, it makes the decolonization process an easier sell, I think, to sort of conservative minded people in Britain. And I suppose the contrast is with France, where the monarchical role is played by the president, but he's also a politician. Right. So de Gaulle has to play both roles in that. So de Gaulle, with Algeria, let's say, he goes to Algeria and he says, I'm on your side, I understand you. And yet at the same time, he has to crack on with the dismantling while in public, she is the smiling, friendly, emollient face of the Commonwealth. But within Britain, so by the 60s, her association with the Commonwealth, with overseas
她是真心享受其中。她非常严肃对待英联邦。而且我认为，正如你所说，这让去殖民化进程对英国那些保守思想的人来说更容易接受一些。我想，这与法国形成了对比，在法国，君主制角色由总统扮演，但他同时也是个政治家。没错。因此戴高乐必须在其中兼顾两个角色。所以戴高乐在阿尔及利亚问题上，比方说，他去阿尔及利亚说，我站在你们这边，我理解你们。然而与此同时，他必须推进解体工作；而在公开场合，女王则是英联邦微笑、友好、温和的面孔。但在英国国内，到了20世纪60年代，她与英联邦、海外
territories, with all this kind of stuff, and the sense of viceroys with plumed helmets which still faintly lurking in the background this is coming to seem ever tweedier and more fusty isn't it as britain starts to swing and i know that you will say well britain was still a very conservative country in the 60s i i entirely accept that you ever heard me say that before? Sure enough. But the sense that she can't play Queen Victoria, that is not her role. So what is her role? And so the sense I have, and again, very happy to be corrected on this because I suspect that it's a stereotype that can be complicated,
领地以及所有这类事物的联系，还有那些隐约潜藏在背景中带着插羽头盔的总督的感觉——随着英国开始摇摆，这一切开始显得越来越陈腐、越来越过时，不是吗？我知道你会说英国在60年代依然是一个非常保守的国家，我完全接受这一点。你以前听我这么说过吗？当然。但她不能扮演维多利亚女王的那种感觉——那不是她的角色。那么她的角色是什么？因此，我的直觉是——同样，非常欢迎对此进行纠正，因为我怀疑这是一种可以被复杂化分析的刻板印象——
but that she decides that they're going to play the role of the first family. They're a normal family. Yeah, absolutely right. So the first criticism comes much earlier than people think. The first criticism comes about 1955, 56, 57. People are sort of outspoken journalists who like to be contrarians. So the tone is very, very reverential in the 50s, but you have people like Malcolm M outspoken journalists who like to be contrarians so the tone is very very reverential in the 50s but you have people like malcolm muggeridge who says uh people think the
但她决定他们将扮演第一家庭的角色。他们是一个普通的家庭。是的，完全正确。所以最初的批评出现得比人们想象的要早得多。最初的批评大约在1955、1956、1957年左右出现。人们是一些喜欢特立独行的直言不讳的记者。因此50年代的基调非常非常崇敬，但你有一些人，比如马尔科姆·喜欢特立独行的直言不讳的记者，所以50年代的基调非常非常崇敬，但你有一些人，比如马尔科姆·马格里奇（Malcolm Muggeridge），他说，人们认为
whole show is out of hand most famously uh the historian john grigg lord alteringham he uh biographer of david lloyd george he you know is close to the court. He writes articles in which he says, her speechwriters make her sound like a priggish schoolgirl and a pain in the neck. And this is incredibly controversial. I mean, he was punched in the face by a member of the League of Empire Loyalists who shouted at the time, punched him in the face and shouted,
整个事情已经失控了。最著名的要数历史学家约翰·格里格（John Grigg，奥尔特灵厄姆勋爵），他是大卫·劳埃德·乔治的传记作家，他和宫廷关系密切。他写文章说，她的演讲稿撰写人让她听起来像个自以为是的优等生，令人讨厌。这引发了极大的争议。我的意思是，他曾被“帝国忠诚者联盟”（League of Empire Loyalists）的一名成员殴打面部，当时那人一边打他一边大喊，
take that from the League of Empire Loyalists, which is an extraordinary thing. So is it the phrase, a British Shintoism? Was it Philip Murphy coined this idea that you can't, you know, that this is a kind of blasphemy to insult a queen like that? And so then that goes away again. It kind of bubbles back up with the satire boom of 1963. That was the week that was and so on.
“尝尝帝国忠诚者联盟的厉害吧”，这真是一件非同寻常的事。所以这是不是那个词，一种“英国的神道教”？是不是菲利普·墨菲（Philip Murphy）创造了这种观点，即你不能——你知道的，侮辱女王是一种亵渎？然后这种情绪又消失了。随着1963年讽刺热潮的兴起，它再次浮出水面。当时有那个节目叫《这就是那周》（That Was The Week That Was）等等。
And there is a sort of sense, I think, particularly when the empire begins to fragment. Peregrine Worsthorn, the future Sunday Telegraph editor, writes at the time, he says, if the empire goes, if we lose all these institutions and all this sort of flummery, he thinks the monarchy will go down with it because he thinks the monarchy is so closely bound up with empire. And so it's a very important sort of, again, is it a bit of spin? Is it a trick to reposition the royal family as the idealized nuclear family? So that's when you
并且有一种感觉，特别是当帝国开始解体时。未来的《星期日电讯报》编辑佩里格林·沃斯特霍恩（Peregrine Worsthorn）当时写道，他认为如果帝国消亡，如果我们失去了所有这些机构和所有这些繁文缛节，他认为君主制也会随之崩溃，因为他认为君主制与帝国紧密相连。所以这是一种非常重要的——再次强调，这究竟是一点公关包装？还是将王室重新定位为理想化核心家庭的一个把戏？所以就在那时，
get things like the documentary Royal Family, which was commissioned in 1968 and then came out in 1969. This is the Queen barbecuing with Philip and Charles. It's actually never been repeated, I think, Tom. Yeah. And that shows Nixon, doesn't it? Yes, because he visited at precisely this point, 68, 69. He was inaugurated in January 69.
你看到了诸如1968年委托制作、1969年播出的纪录片《王室》（Royal Family）。这就是女王与菲利普和查尔斯一起在烤肉的场景。汤姆，事实上这部片子后来再也没有重播过，我想。是的。这还展现了尼克松，对吧？是的，因为他恰好在这个时期访问过，即68、69年。他在69年1月就职。
And this thing, you know, this is sort of we're a normal family, just like you. And people comment at the time. So the Archbishop of Canterbury in 1964, I think, says Britain is lucky to have around the throne a Christian family, united, happy, and setting to war. An example of what the words home and family should mean. Oh, dear. I mean, that will, you know, it's a brilliant, united, happy, and setting to war with what the words home and family should mean. Oh dear.
而这件事，你知道的，这有点像我们在说“我们是一个普通家庭，就像你们一样”。当时人们也发表了评论。因此，坎特伯雷大主教在1964年左右曾说，英国很幸运，在王位周围拥有一个基督教家庭，团结、幸福，并为世人树立了榜样。
I mean, that will, you know, it's a brilliant, as I said, hostage to fortune. It's a brilliant bit of political presentation, if it works. If it works. I was told a brilliant story yesterday by my friend, Jamie Muir, who is the son of Frank Muir. And Frank Muir in the, I think, mid-60s, or maybe a bit later, maybe 70s, went to Buckingham Palace for tea.
一个关于“家”和“家庭”这些词应该意味着什么的好榜样。天哪。我的意思是，这会——你知道的，正如我所说，这是一个送上门来的笑柄。如果成功的话，这绝对是一次绝妙的政治公关呈现。如果成功的话。昨天我的朋友杰米·缪尔（Jamie Muir，弗兰克·缪尔的儿子）给我讲了一个精彩的故事。弗兰克·缪尔在我想是60年代中期，或者可能稍晚一点，大约70年代，去白金汉宫喝茶。
They all kind of sat around. And they were talking about adverts and the power of advertising. And the Queen said, yes, you know, they said how it sways you. And she said, yes, that if she had to buy a drill um she would buy a black and decker and and um so she's watching a lot of itv she's watching a lot of itv so i mean i think that's a kind of wonderful thought that she's sat around with her tupperware watching black and decker adverts and apparently um frank me a few months later met the head of black and decker and said i've got you the best slogan you can never
大家坐在一起。他们谈到了广告和广告的力量。女王说，是的，你知道的，他们谈到广告是如何左右人的。女王说，是的，如果她必须买一个电钻，嗯，她会买一个百得（Black & Decker），而且——所以她看了很多独立电视台（ITV）的节目。她看了很多ITV的节目——所以我的意思是，我认为这是一个美妙的想法：她坐在那里用着特百惠，看着百得电钻的广告。而且显然，嗯，弗兰克·缪尔几个月后遇到了百得的负责人，并说：“我给你想出了一个你永远无法使用的最佳标语——”
use oh yeah so they have to keep it quiet but there is that sense isn't there that you know the queen is you know she she she's very abstemious tupperware using black and decker drills all that kind of thing uh and a model family and that absolutely then sets up for the uh the kind of the great crisis of her reign really which is yeah if it kicks in from the 70s onwards so it's interesting how how politics plays such a small part in all this because of course she's had a labor government from 1964 under harold wilson but she gets on brilliantly with wilson gets on pretty well with most of his ministers except only ben right who wants to take her head off the stamps and she's not having that. Wants to take her head off the stamps, which she plays a very canny game. She doesn't say no.
哦，是的，所以他们必须对此保持低调。但确实有那种感觉，不是吗？你知道，女王是一个——她非常简朴，用特百惠，用百得电钻，诸如此类的一切——而且是一个模范家庭，这绝对为后来她统治时期真正的重大危机做好了铺垫——也就是，是的，如果从70年代开始爆发的话。所以有趣的是，政治在这一切中只扮演了如此微不足道的角色，因为当然，自1964年起她在哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）领导下经历了一个工党政府，但她与威尔逊相处得极其融洽，和他的大多数大臣也相处得相当不错，除了托尼·本恩（Tony Benn）——他想把她的头像从邮票上撤下来，而她对此坚决不从。想把她的头像从邮票上撤下来，对此她采取了一种非常精明的策略。她没有说不。
She just says, well, I'll have a look at them. And there's this sort of, Ben commissions all these stamps and shows the Queen. She smiles and she nods and basically she knows the Wilson. So Harold Wilson, who is the sort of Mr. White Heater technology, but he's also the former boy scout who takes the scouting oath so seriously. So it's the essence of his socialism. And he is the world's biggest monarchist, and there's no way he's ever going to take the Queen's head off the stamps. So she plays this waiting game and Ben fumes in the post office tower
她只是说，好吧，我会看看它们的。然后出现了这样一种情况，本恩委托设计了所有这些邮票并展示给女王看。她微笑着点点头，基本上她了解威尔逊。所以哈罗德·威尔逊——他是那种“科技白热化”先生，但他也是一个极其认真对待童子军誓言的前童子军。所以这是他社会主义的精髓。而且他是世界上头号的保皇党人，他绝无可能把女王的头像从邮票上撤下来。所以她玩这种拖延战术，而本恩则在邮政塔（Post Office Tower）里，或者在他藏身的某个地方愤怒地生闷气，因为他无法把她的头像从邮票上弄下来。但政治所扮演的角色是如此……我的意思是，关键的主角是媒体，而不是政治。所以如果你回想当——我想你会说问题在70年代开始积聚，这并不令人意外，因为对英国来说这是一个充满冲突的十年，是国际货币基金组织（IMF）救助、三天工作制和不满之冬的十年。但这些事情实际上根本不是因素。真正的问题，我认为，是媒体开始变得更加民粹主义。在我想是1976年，《太阳报》超越了《每日镜报》。
or wherever he's holed up in rage that he can't get her head off the stamps. But the politics plays so... I mean, the key protagonist is the media, not politics. So if you think when... I suppose you would say the problem starts to mount up in the 70s, which is not surprising because it's a terribly conflicted decade for Britain, the decade of the IMF bailout and the three-day week and the winter discontent. But those things actually are not a factor at all. The real problem, I think, is that the media starts to become more populist. And you have the sun overtakes the mirror in, I think, 1976.
而那一年，当然也是玛格丽特公主宣布与摄影师安东尼·阿姆斯特朗-琼斯（斯诺登勋爵）离婚的年份。这两件事巧合在一起，你拥有了第一桩真正重大的王室丑闻故事，但与此同时，两个民粹主义小报之间爆发了激烈的发行量战争。这两件事的巧合对君主制来说是具有毁灭性的。而且《太阳报》是由鲁珀特·默多克（Rupert Murdoch）拥有的，他是一个澳大利亚共和主义者。是的。所以这大概也是其中的一个因素吧。我的意思是，他是第一个共和主义报业大亨吗？哦，这是个好问题，汤姆。他大概是的。是的，他很可能。但我认为，即使他不是共和主义者，公共生活的基调也在朝着那个方向发展。它不再盲目顺从。它是个人主义的。它对机构持批判态度。向旧建制开炮，向那些让英国失望的机构开炮，
And that, of course, is the year when Princess Margaret's divorce from the photographer anti-Armstrong Jones, Lord Snowden, is announced. And the coincidence of those two things, you've got the first really juicy royal scandal story, but at the same time, you have this intense circulation war between two populist tabloids. And the coincidence of those two things is toxic for the monarchy. And also the Sun is owned by Rupert Murdoch, who is an Australian Republican. Yeah. So that presumably is an element to it as well. I mean, is he the first Republican press baron? Oh, that's a good question, Tom. He probably is. Yes, he probably is. But I think even had he not been a Republican, the tenor of public life is moving in that direction. It's undifferential. It's individualistic. It's critical of institutions. tilting at the old establishment, tilting at institutions that have let Britain down,
这种具有攻击性的民粹主义文化，从70年代中期开始变得越来越喧嚣。而这就是撒切尔夫人与女王关系的矛盾所在，不是吗？一方面，很显然，撒切尔夫人是一位保守党人。她忠于君主制，忠于女王，每次见到女王时都会行夸张的屈膝礼。但另一方面，她是一个激进派。例如——众所周知，她怀疑的事情之一就是英联邦。所以我们之前谈到过女王作为联合王国女王兼英联邦元首的角色之间的张力，以及贯穿整个80年代围绕如何处理南非种族隔离问题而爆发的种种争论。
this sort of aggressive populist culture, which you see ever more vociferous from the mid-70s onwards. And that's the paradox of Mrs. Thatcher's relationship to the Queen, isn't it? That on the one hand, obviously, Mrs. Thatcher is a conservative. She is devoted to the monarchy, devoted to the Queen, extravagant curtsies whenever she meets the queen. But on the other hand, she is a radical. And for instance, I mean, notoriously, one of the things that she is sceptical about is the Commonwealth. And so we were talking about the tension between the queen's role as the queen of the United Kingdom and head of the Commonwealth and all the arguments that blaze up throughout the 80s over what to do about apartheid South Africa.
而女王对撒切尔夫人顽固拒绝实施制裁的做法感到非常非常沮丧。是的，绝对如此。汤姆，完全正确。所以实际上具有讽刺意味的是，你曾有过两位工党首相，哈罗德·威尔逊和吉姆·卡拉汉。汤姆，我们不能录制一期关于女王统治的播客而不提到——不，“人民的首相”。托尼·吉姆，“人民的首相”。
And the Queen becomes very, very upset about Mrs. Thatcher's obduracy in refusing to impose sanctions. Yeah, absolutely. That's absolutely right, Tom. So actually the irony is that you've had two Labour prime ministers, Harold Wilson and Jim Callaghan. We can't do a podcast about the Queen's reign, Tom, without mentioning. No, the people's prime minister. Tony Jim, the people's prime minister.
所以她经历过两位工党首相，他们在卡拉汉和威尔逊身上可能是她整个统治时期最忠诚的两个保皇党人。我的意思是，他们绝不容许听到半句批评君主制的话，对女王极其恭顺。而且显而易见，你可以从照片和电影中看出，他们热爱与她共度的每一刻。然后撒切尔夫人上台了。而撒切尔夫人，尽管正如你所说，
So she's had two Labour prime ministers who are probably the two most devoted monarchists of her entire reign in Callaghan and Wilson. I mean, they will not hear a word of criticism of the monarchy and are incredibly deferential to the Queen. And patently, you can tell from photographs and films, they love every moment they spend in her company. And then Mrs. Thatcher comes in. And Mrs. Thatcher, although, as you say,
她对英国历史有一种浪漫的想法——当人们谈论撒切尔夫人时经常忽略这一点——她会行巨大的屈膝礼以及所有诸如此类的事情，但她认为，王宫是她眼中那种带有粉红色、软弱、无能、无脊椎、向社会主义妥协并出卖立场的软弱建制派的化身。所以撒切尔夫人绝对坚信
she has this romantic idea of Britain's history, which I think people often miss when they're talking about Mrs. Thatcher, and she does these massive curtsies and all that sort of stuff. She thinks, I think, that the palace is the incarnation of what she sees as the pinkish, wet, weedy, lily-livered, chinless establishment who have sold out to socialism and all this sort of thing. So Mrs Thatcher is absolutely adamant there
绝不会实施制裁。她不同意对南非种族隔离政权实施制裁，她认为这不管用。实际上，再次强调——我认为很多人忽略了这一点——她其实是在幕后试图向南非种族隔离政府施加压力，但（在她看来）他们是冷战盟友，而她只是认为屈服于这种压力是软弱无力的表现。女王对此感到震惊，真的是大为震惊，并认为这在社会上具有分裂性。据推测，这——我的意思是，我们永远不知道宫廷会面时究竟发生了什么，但我想大家都一致认为，这导致唐宁街和王宫之间的关系发生了可怕的冷淡。我的意思是，据撒切尔夫人的所有助手说，她读到这篇报道时感到痛心疾首。我的意思是，她只是觉得这是最糟糕的事情。
will be no sanctions she doesn't agree with sanctions on the apartheid regime in south africa she doesn't think they work she is actually again i think a lot of people miss this she she is trying to put pressure on the apartheid government sort of behind the scenes but you know she sees them as a cold war ally and she she just thinks it's weedy and wet to give into pressure on this. The Queen is aghast, is really aghast, and socially divisive. And supposedly this, you know, I mean, we never know what goes on in the audiences, but I think everybody's agreed this causes a terrible cooling of relations between Downing Street and the palace. I mean, Mrs. Thatcher, by all her aid, say she was gutted when she read this. I mean, she just thought this was the most awful thing.
她简直不敢相信白金汉宫竟然允许这种事出现在报纸上。而且她觉得自己被严重不公地对待了。我绝对认为，对于女王来说——实际上你在这里看到的是两个女人，她们的整个职业生涯都围绕着与男人打交道，而不是与其他女人，特别是撒切尔夫人而言。因此缺乏这种默契，她们谁也无法按照自己一贯习惯的方式来扮演角色。我认为女王确实尊重撒切尔夫人，
She couldn't believe that the Buckingham Palace had allowed this to appear in the newspapers. And she thinks she's been incredibly hard done by. And I definitely think that for the quick, you know, actually what you have here is two women whose entire working lives have revolved around dealing with men not with other women um and particularly in mrs thatcher's case actually and so that lack of a rapport neither of them can play the part in a way that they've always been accustomed to. And I think the Queen respected Mrs. Thatcher, you know,
作为一名女性，作为一个赢得过三次大选胜利的人等等。但绝对不认为这是一段亲密温暖的关系。不，她更喜欢奥尔森（Wilson）。哦，当然。我的意思是，当威尔逊去巴尔莫勒尔时，威尔逊基本上辞职了，他告诉女王他要辞职，当时他们在一间巴尔莫勒尔的小屋里一起喝茶，
as a woman, as somebody who was a three-time election winner and all these kinds of things. But I definitely don't think it was a warm relationship by any means. No, she preferred to her Orson. Oh, definitely. I mean, when Wilson would go to Balmoral, I mean, Wilson resigned, basically told the Queen he was going to resign, when they've had tea together in a cottage at Balmoral
她还在帮他洗碗。是的。我的意思是，很难想象她和撒切尔夫人之间会是这样，她们之间大概会为了谁来洗碗而争吵。好吧，这就是女王在80年代不得不面对的第一场重大危机。
and she's helping him doing the washing up. Yeah. I mean, it's hard to imagine. With her and Mrs. Thatcher, it would be an argument about who's going to do the washing up. Right. So that's kind of the first great crisis that the Queen has to face up to in the 80s.
然后还有另一场危机，不是吗？嗯，以黛安娜的出现为代表，你是这个意思吧。以黛安娜为代表。因为，我的意思是，基本上女王不再是王室中最著名的女性成员了，这一定是个不小的打击。没错，汤姆。但我忍不住注意到，你正在轻描淡写地略过某些事情，
And then there's another one, isn't there? Well, in the person of just Diana, you mean. In the person of Diana. Because, I mean, basically the Queen is no longer the most famous female member of the royal family, which must have been quite a shock. That's right, Tom. But I can't help noticing that you're skating over something,
我猜是出于你自己的政治原因，因为你知道接下来会发生什么。你知道接下来会发生什么。所以，汤姆，对于那些不知道的人来说，汤姆在这档播客中经常以坦率说得没完没了的篇幅，谈论过爱德华王子对汤姆作品的钦佩。而且你有过记录，不是吗，汤姆，说过无论温莎王朝发生什么样的王位继承危机，你都会视自己为
I suspect for political reasons of your own, because you know what's coming. You know what's coming. So, Tom, for people who don't know, Tom has often spoken in this podcast at frankly interminable length about Prince Edward's admiration for Tom's works. And you're on record, aren't you, Tom, saying that wherever a House of Windsor succession crisis, you would consider yourself
爱德华王子的旗手。我想那是——我已经向爱德华王子效忠了。这是真的。所以当然，我的意思是，你知道，爱德华王子像女王的其他孩子一样，在20世纪80年代也在寻找自己的角色。
Prince Edward's bannerman. I think that was the... I have sworn my sword to Prince Edward. That is true. So of course, I mean, you know, Prince Edward, like the other, the Queen's other children, is now looking for a role in the 1980s.
他们拥有女王在饱受战争蹂躏的英国所没有的那种选择权。没错，因为他们不是两次世界大战期间、世界大战时代以及集体责任时代产物。他们在试图寻找自己的定位。
And they have the kind of choice that the Queen didn't have in war-torn Britain. Right, because they're not the products of the interwar years and the World War era and the era of collective responsibility and all these things. They're trying to find their own niches. in prince edward's case part of his niche involves staging this thing called um it's actually called the grand knockout tournament
就爱德华王子而言，他的定位的一部分涉及策划一件被称为——其实它被称为“宏大淘汰赛锦标赛”（Grand Knockout Tournament），
but it's better known as it's a royal knockout in june 1987 as a great admirer of prince edward you will remember this occasion well it's a learning curve. It's like Prince Hal becomes Henry V. Prince Edward, who directed this, I'm not going to in any way defend it, will go on to become Edward the Great. Edward the Great, very good, yes. So, I mean, it's got George Lazenby, it's got Barbara Winter, it's got John Travolta chasing cliff richard dressed as a leak it's actually got i have to say dressed as a leak i think because they're dressed as the
但它更广为人知的名字是“王室淘汰赛”（It's a Royal Knockout），于1987年6月举行。作为爱德华王子的崇拜者，你会清楚地记得这个场合。这是一个学习曲线。就像哈尔王子变成亨利五世一样。亲自导演了这场的爱德华王子——我绝不会为它辩护——后来将成为“伟大的爱德华”。伟大的爱德华，非常棒，是的。所以，我的意思是，里面有乔治·拉赞比（George Lazenby）、芭芭拉·温特（Barbara Windsor），还有约翰·特拉沃尔塔（John Travolta）追赶着打扮成韭葱的克里夫·理查德（Cliff Richard）。实际上，我必须说，打扮成韭葱，我想是因为他们打扮成了
symbols of the united kingdom maybe there must be somebody dressed as a leak i mean actually they're dressed as a daffodil i don't know actually i mean you know i'm feeling embarrassed about it i'm not embarrassed about that i think that's a kind of surreal genius lewis carroll would have been proud of that he would and there's actually another reason why you shouldn't feel embarrassed about it because the company that produces our podcast, Goldhanger Films, Goldhanger Podcasts, is owned by another participant in its Raw Knockout, Gary Lineker. So Gary, if you're listening, you will remember this very well.
联合王国的象征，也许吧。一定有人打扮成韭葱。我的意思是，实际上他们打扮成了一朵黄水仙，其实我也不知道。我的意思是，你知道的，我对此感到有些尴尬。我对此并不感到尴尬，我认为这有一种超现实的天才，刘易斯·卡罗尔（Lewis Carroll）都会为此感到骄傲。他确实会。而且还有另一个原因让你不应该对此感到尴尬，因为制作我们播客的公司——戈德亨格电影公司（Goldhanger Films）、戈德亨格播客公司——是由《王室淘汰赛》的另一位参与者加里·莱因克尔（Gary Lineker）拥有的。所以加里，如果你在听的话，你会对这个记忆犹新。
So anyway, yes, that's a – What was Gary Dress does? I mean, he can... A race or a unicorn or something. A thistle. Let's say a unicorn, even though I'm not sure. A lion. You'd have been a lion, wouldn't you?
所以无论如何，是的，那是一个——加里当时打扮成什么？我的意思是，他可以——一匹赛马、独角兽之类的东西。一朵蓟花。我们就算是一只独角兽吧，尽管我不太确定。一头狮子。你当时会是一头狮子，对吧？
One of the three lions. It's a royal knockout. And the press reaction to it, which is very scathing, is in its sort of silly way, it does reflect a deeper issue, which is the press are much more feral than they were at the beginning of the Queen's reign. Her children are of an age when there are going to be ups and downs. And obviously, the biggest issue becomes Diana. So you have the dissolution of various marriages, but the implosion of the marriage of Prince Charles and Diana,
三头狮子之一。这就是《王室淘汰赛》。媒体对它的反应非常尖刻，用一种愚蠢的方式，它确实反映了一个更深层次的问题，那就是媒体比女王统治初期要凶猛得多。她的孩子们正处于会有起伏波动的年龄。显然，最大的问题变成了黛安娜。所以你有了各种婚姻的解体，但查尔斯王子和黛安娜婚姻的内爆，
I think obviously the trouble is that what it does is that it plants a bomb at the heart of that image that they have created since the 1960s and an image that nods back to george v and george the sixth her great predecessors right so so it it puts a bomb under the idea of them as a the first family a kind of model family but doesn't it also i mean diana's emphasis on expressing your feelings living your truth all that kind of stuff is very very contrary to the Queen's stoical, you know, stiff upper lip, rattle on, all that kind of stuff. And it makes her, what have always been seen as her virtues, look like problems, that they're old fashioned, they're out of tune. And so when Diana dies, you know, show us you care, mom.
我认为显而易见的问题在于，它在他们自20世纪60年代以来精心打造的那个形象的核心埋下了一颗炸弹，这个形象呼应了她的伟大前任乔治五世和乔治六世，对吧？所以它在“第一家庭”、“模范家庭”这种概念的底下安放了一颗炸弹。但这难道不是也意味着——我的意思是，黛安娜强调表达真实感受、活出自我诸如此类的事情，与女王那坚忍的、咬紧牙关、硬挺过去的作风背道而驰。这使得女王那些一直被视为美德的品质看起来像是问题所在，显得老气、与时代脱节。所以当黛安娜去世时，“向我们展示你在乎，妈妈”，
That was the headline, wasn't it? It was indeed. Absolutely. It was the sum. You know, the Queen isn't in the business. I mean, I suppose she would say she shows that she cares in her own way. And we talked at the beginning, you know, the genius of that image of her at the funeral of the Duke of Edinburgh. But Diana's way of showing that she cares was a much more overt one.
这就是当时的头条新闻，不是吗？确实如此。绝对是的。这就是《太阳报》。你知道，女王不在那个行当里。我的意思是，我想她会说她用自己的方式表达了她在乎。我们在一开始也谈到过，你知道，她在菲利普亲王葬礼上的那个形象具有天才般的感染力。但黛安娜表达关怀的方式要直白得多。
Yeah. And therefore, the kind of thing that could be more readily photographed and put in the sun and and the queen that was the great crisis point for her wasn't it yeah i think it's a series of tensions actually tom it's it's that absolutely as you say it's the the tension between what i frankly greatly prefer which is a um an ethos of of sort of uh bottling everything up and not talking about it. That's one way of putting it. But I think a sense of, you know, you deal with things with dignity. You don't air all your linen in public.
因此，这种事情更容易被拍照并登在《太阳报》上。女王的这一危机时刻对她来说是最大的危机点，不是吗？是的，我认为这是一系列张力的交织，汤姆。这就是——绝对如你所说，这是我坦白说更喜欢的精神气质之间的张力，也就是一种将所有情绪都封存起来、绝不宣泄的精神气质。这是一种说法。但我认为有一种感觉，你知道的，你应当以尊严来处理事情。你不要把所有的家丑都公之于众。
That there is a value in restraint and in taciturnity and these kinds of things, an understatement. And, of course, the alternative view, which is you should air your linen in public, there's a great value in the public display of empathy and emotion and all this sort of stuff. I mean, probably most of our listeners would say they fall somewhere in between those two things. So there's that, but there's also the tension between the private and the public.
克制和沉默寡言以及诸如此类的事情是有价值的，轻描淡写也是有价值的。当然，另一种观点则认为，你应该把家丑公之于众，公开展示同理心和情感具有巨大的价值。我的意思是，可能我们的大多数听众会说他们介于这两者之间。所以存在这种张力，但同时也存在私人与公众之间的张力。
So her reaction to the death of Diana is actually she thinks her responsibility should be to William and Harry, her children. And she thinks, well, that's obviously my focus. But there you have probably the greatest example in her reign of something where there is this great conflict between what she sees as her role as a grandmother and indeed a mother and her role as a sort of avatar of national identity and she's expected to by the public to reflect value and represent values that ultimately she doesn't really hold i suppose and that's why that's such a it's it's also that's i think that was a an extraordinary moment and i i i say most people, maybe I'm just projecting my own prejudices onto this, and some listeners may well say that I am, but I suspect most people now
因此，她对黛安娜之死的反应实际上是认为她的责任应该对威廉和哈利（她的孙子们）负责，这是她的孩子们。她认为，嗯，这显然是我的重点。但正是在这里，你拥有了她统治时期最伟大的例子，其中存在着巨大的冲突：一方面是她作为祖母甚至是母亲的角色，另一方面是她作为国家认同化身的角色；公众期望她去反映和代表那些最终她自己并不真正认同的价值观，我想这就是为什么这是一个如此——这也是一个非同寻常的时刻。我——我说大多数人，也许我只是将我自己的偏见投射到了这一点上，一些听众也可能会说我是这样，但我怀疑大多数人现在
feel faintly embarrassed about what happened in 1997. Do you think, Tom? Well, so we've talked about the crown a lot, haven't we, over the course of this? And that is fascinating as an example of how the Queen is someone whose life can be mythologized even while she's alive. I mean, it's kind of almost Shakespearean process of turning the stuff of royal drama into literal drama. looking at the events of Diana's death and her funeral through the Queen's eyes and I would guess that that would be representative of a slight gear shift in the wake of Diana's death that actually the Queen eased into a new role as I suppose really the country's grandmother I mean that's a stereotype isn't it i'm sounding like hugh edwards there you're back in hugh edwards i'm back in edward hugh edwards mode but it's a great mode to be in actually i'm not knocking hugh edwards at all i think he's
对1997年发生的事情会感到隐隐的尴尬。你觉得呢，汤姆？嗯，所以我们在整个过程中讨论了很多关于《王冠》这部剧，对吧？作为一个关于女王如何成为一个即使在她生前也可以被神话化的人物，这非常迷人。我的意思是，这几乎是一种将王室戏剧的素材转化为字面戏剧的莎士比亚式的过程。透过女王的眼睛来看待黛安娜之死和她的葬礼，我会猜想这代表了在黛安娜去世之后心态的一次微调，事实上女王平稳地过渡到了一个新的角色，我想真的就是这个国家的祖母。我的意思是，这是一种刻板印象，不是吗？我听起来像休·爱德华兹（Huw Edwards）了。你又回到休·爱德华兹模式了。我回到了休·爱德华兹模式，但实际上这是一个很棒的模式，我一点也没有贬低休·爱德华兹的意思，我认为他
doing an amazing job i think the queen proves brilliant at that yeah and but but and it may be that people expect their grandparents actually to have different standards and approaches. And that's precisely why you value them. Yeah, that's actually very astute, Tom. I think I agree with you. I think there was definitely a gear shift. And I think that film does capture it because, of course, the funny thing is that in 1997 at the time, it'd be interesting to know what our sister podcast, The Rest Is Politics, makes of this. Of course, Alastair Campbell's involvement.
做得非常棒。我认为女王证明了自己在这一点上极其出色。是的，而且——但人们可能确实期望他们的祖父母拥有不同的标准和处事方式。这正是你珍视他们的原因。是的，汤姆，这其实非常敏锐。我想我同意你的看法。我认为确实有过一次心态的微调。而且我认为那部电影确实捕捉到了这一点，因为当然，有趣的是，在1997年当时，了解我们的姐妹播客《历史就是政治》（The Rest Is Politics）对这件事有何看法会很有趣。当然还有阿斯代尔·坎贝尔（Alastair Campbell）的参与。
At the time, there was a sense that Tony Blair, she was the people's princess. He had caught the mood of the nation and the Queen had not. But by the time the film The Queen came out, Tony Blair was now on the sort of always getting kickings from the public. The public had sort of wearied of Tony Blair. And actually, in that film, it is the queen rather than blair who is the real protagonist and who with whom ultimately you're really invited to empathize i would say yeah definitely you're invited to respect her her self-restraint her self-discipline and so on and you're i think
当时有一种感觉，托尼·布莱尔——她是“人民的王妃”。他捕捉到了国民的情绪，而女王没有。但当电影《女王》上映时，托尼·布莱尔现在正处于不断遭到公众痛斥的境地。公众对托尼·布莱尔有些厌倦了。事实上，在那部电影中，真正的主角是女王而不是布莱尔，最终你真正被邀请去产生共鸣的是女王，我会这么说。是的，绝对的。你被邀请去尊重她的自我克制、自我纪律等等。而且我认为，
you are invited very subtly is it to laugh at or to recoil from Tony Blair's kind of shiny facility? Well, I'm not sure about that, because I think that Peter Morgan then went on to write a play, The Audience. Yes. Yeah. In which it wasn't just that the Queen was seeing Blair, it was also all the other prime ministers. And that play in turn inspired Netflix to commission The Crown. And what Peter Morgan is focusing on, which he could do by the time he, you know, because the Queen was starting to knock up an incredible array of jubilees by this point,
你被邀请以非常微妙的方式——是去嘲笑还是退避于托尼·布莱尔那种光鲜流利的外表？嗯，这一点我不太确定，因为我认为彼得·摩根（Peter Morgan）后来去写了一部戏剧《观众》（The Audience）。是的。是的。在这部剧中，不仅是女王在会见布莱尔，还有所有其他的首相。而这部剧反过来启发了网飞（Netflix）委托制作《王冠》。彼得·摩根所关注的是——当他——你知道的，因为女王此时已经开始积累起令人难以置信的一系列银禧庆典了，
I mean, she was kind of knocking them out of the park, was the sense of just how remarkably long lived she was, and how remarkable it was that this woman had met so many prime ministers. So I think it's not that it's mocking Blair as an inherently comic figure. But it sees him as transitory, doesn't it? It sees him as transitory, exactly. And that the self-conceit of a prime minister is as nothing compared to a monarch who has seen them come and go. And I think that that is a crucial part of the affection that the Queen has been held in in Britain over the past, say, two or 25 years perhaps.
我的意思是，她简直是在轻松打破纪录——他关注的是她那惊人的长寿感，以及这个女人曾会见过如此多的首相是多么的非凡。所以我认为这并不是在嘲讽布莱尔是一个天生的喜剧人物。而是将他视为短暂的，不是吗？正是将他视为短暂的。而且首相的自负与一个见证了他们来来去去的君主相比，简直微不足道。我认为这是女王在过去25年左右里赢得英国民众喜爱的一个至关重要的部分。
Yeah. It's the sense that she is a living embodiment of a vast sweep of time. I think that's right, Tom. I think there was definitely a point in the early 21st century where people did what they had never done in the 80s. I mean, people in the 80s and 90s never said, gosh, isn't it extraordinary? She knew Attlee Churchill.
是的。那种感觉是，她是庞大时间跨度的活生生的化身。我认为这是对的，汤姆。我认为在21世纪初确实有一个时刻，人们做了他们在80年代从未做过的事。我的意思是，80年代和90年代的人绝不会说：“天哪，这难道不非凡吗？她竟然认识艾礼和丘吉尔。”
I mean, Attlee wasn't one of her prime ministers, but he was waiting for her on the tarmac when her plane touched down after she had become queen, that she knew Attlee Churchill. She knew Eden and Macmillan and all of these people. I mean, people didn't say that in the 1980s and 90s. Of course she knew them. But I think there was definitely a point in the early 21st century when people suddenly started to say, oh, my God,
我的意思是，艾attle（艾德礼）虽然不是她的首相之一，但在她登基后专机降落时，他却在停机坪上等着她。她认识艾德礼、丘吉尔。她认识艾登、麦克米伦和所有这些人。我的意思是，在20世纪80年代和90年代，人们不会这么说。当然她认识他们。但我觉得在21世纪初，确实出现了一个转折点，人们突然开始说，天哪，
Winston Churchill was her first prime minister. Isn't that extraordinary? I mean, we were talking in the first podcast about how we had this week's events not happened. We would have now been recording our episodes about the young churchill which we will do in due course i mean it is extraordinary that her first prime minister went into a cavalry charge at the battle of omdurman i mean what a what an incredible story that is and i think it comes to be seen as extraordinary as well by people
温斯顿·丘吉尔是她的第一任首相。这不是很了不起吗？我的意思是，我们在第一期播客中谈到，如果本周的事件没有发生，我们本该录制关于年轻丘吉尔的剧集了，我们以后也会这么做。我的意思是，她的第一任首相曾在恩图曼战役中冲入骑兵冲锋，这真是太不可思议了，这是多么了不起的故事啊。我认为这也开始被人们视为非凡之举，
of other countries so you know for americans know, she's met every president except for Lyndon Johnson. Or France, she's met every French president. And I think that, you know, people around the world can look at her and see her, you know, she is this astonishingly famous woman who provides contact with, or in India, she met Nehru. I mean, it's astonishing, I think, not just for people in Britain. And I think that that's why her death has had a kind of the global resonance that it's had. Well, there was an extraordinary statistic I saw yesterday, Tom. When I'm thinking about it, it's probably true that her life since 1926 spans 30% of the lifespan of the United States. Yeah, it's amazing, isn't it?
来自其他国家的人也是如此。所以你知道，对于美国人来说，她见过了除林登·约翰逊之外的所有美国总统。或者法国，她见过了每一位法国总统。我认为，世界各地的人们看着她，就会发现她是一位如此令人惊叹的著名女性，她与外界保持着联系，或者在印度，她见过了尼赫루。我认为这不仅对英国人来说令人惊叹，这也是为什么她的逝世会产生如此全球共鸣的原因。昨天我看到一个非凡的数据，汤姆。仔细想想，这大概是真的：自从1926年以来，她的一生跨越了美国30%的寿命。是的，这太惊人了，不是吗？
Well, so Obama went to the funeral of Shimon Peres. It was a funeral in Israel. And he gave an address and he name-checked giants of the 20th century. So he was, I think it was Peres. He was associating Peres as a giant of the 20th century. So he was, I think it was Perez. He was associating Perez as a giant of the 20th century. And he cited two other people. He cited Nelson Mandela and he cited Elizabeth II. And that's coming from a president whose father was born in Kenya,
奥巴马去参加了希蒙·佩雷斯的葬礼。那是在以色列举行的葬礼。他发表了一篇演讲，并点名提到了20世纪的巨人们。所以他——我想那是佩雷斯。他将佩雷斯视为20世纪的巨人。所以他——我想那是佩雷斯。他将佩雷斯视为20世纪的巨人。他还提到了另外两个人。他提到了纳尔逊·曼德拉，还提到了伊丽莎白二世。这出自一位父亲出生于肯尼亚的总统之口，
the subject of the British Empire. It's quite something, I think. And actually, of all the footage of her meeting dignitaries, I always think that her meeting the Obamas is... Yeah, they obviously really got on, didn't they? Yeah. She loved meeting them. They clearly loved meeting her. The symbolism, it sort of continues that theme that we talked about. She was always clearly very, very comfortable, probably because she had been brought up steeped in empire she that made that in what some listeners may consider a paradoxical way that made her unusually comfortable
大英帝国的子民。这真的很了不起，我想。实际上，在她会见政要的所有镜头中，我总觉得她与奥巴马的会面是……是的，他们显然非常合得来，不是吗？是的。她很喜欢见他们。他们显然也很喜欢见她。这种象征意义，某种程度上延续了我们之前讨论过的主题。她显然一直非常非常自在，可能因为她从小就沉浸在帝国环境中，用一些听众可能认为是矛盾的方式，这让她感到异常自在。
i would say for somebody of her class and and background with black and asian people and i think that's the sort of i mean that's the last night at Buckingham Palace when there were sort of crowds assembling. I mean, it was a very diverse crowd. And the image that people sometimes have abroad, which is that the monarchy in Britain symbolizes fustiness and nostalgia and a sort of reactionary backward looking aspect of Britishness. And there's perhaps an element of truth in that. But I think people outside sometimes miss the extent to which
我想对于她这种阶层和背景的人来说，她对黑人和亚洲人也是如此。我认为这就是——也就是白金汉宫前的最后一晚，当时人群聚集。我的意思是，那是一个非常多元化的群体。人们在海外有时会有这样的印象，即英国的君主制象征着守旧、怀旧以及英国性中某种反动、倒退的方面。这其中或许也有一些真实成分。但我认为局外人有时会忽略这样一种程度，即
that Commonwealth dimension actually really matters. It gives the monarchy an opportunity it wouldn't otherwise have to embrace modernity and to embrace change, I think. Yeah. Don't you think? Yes. Although, of course, there are limits, which have been tested by Harry and Meghan, I suppose.
这种联邦维度其实非常重要。它赋予了君主制一个原本不会有的契机去拥抱现代性，拥抱变革。是的。你不觉得吗？是的。尽管当然也有局限性，这些局限性我想已经被哈里和梅根考验过了。
But the issue there, I think, is not actually. I mean, OK, we did a podcast about Harry and Meghan at the time. I think actually the issue there is not race. No, I don't think it is. I think it's about the different standards of America. I think that, you know, and actually that, I think that that is something that suggests that perhaps the monarchy has not evolved as much as people might think, which is that the problem the monarchy has with Meghan is pretty much the problem that it had with Wallace Simpson. It's the fact that ultimately, although the Queen adores America, has been to
但我想，真正的问题其实不在于——好吧，我们当时做过一期关于哈里和梅根的播客。实际上我认为问题不在于种族。不，我不认为是这样。我认为这是关于美国的不同标准。我认为，而且实际上，这表明君主制可能并没有像人们想象的那样进化了那么多，也就是说，君主制对梅根的问题基本上就是它对沃利斯·辛普森的问题。事实上，尽管女王非常崇拜美国，去过
America loads, has met all the presidents, you know, goes racing there, all that kind of stuff. She embodies a kind of concept of Britain, an idea of Britain that is incompatible with everything that makes America, America. And there is something indigestible, I think, about American culture for that reason. And someone who embodies American culture as kind of flamboyantly as Meghan does, was always going to end in tears, perhaps. Well, there's obviously a generational difference, isn't there? I mean, you talked about Diana and you said, you know, public empathy and indeed used expression, living her truth, which is, of course, a Meghan expression.
美国无数次，见过所有的总统，你知道的，去那里看赛马，诸如此类的事情。她所体现的英国概念、英国理念，与造就美国的一切格格不入。正因如此，美国文化中有些东西是让人难以消化的。而像梅根那样张扬地体现美国文化的人，也许注定会以悲剧收场。好吧，这里显然存在代沟，不是吗？我的意思是，你谈到了戴安娜，你说过，公众的同理心，甚至用了“活出真实的自我”这个表达，这当然也是梅根常用的表达。
That Meghan was sort of Diana turned up to 17. But America is about meritocracy. It's about choice. Megan was sort of Diana turned up to 17. But America is about meritocracy. It's about choice. It's about blazing your own path. I mean, that's the essence of Hollywood. It's the essence of California. That's where they've gone to live.
梅根就像是把戴安娜放大了17倍。但美国讲究的是精英政治。它关乎选择。梅根就像是把戴安娜放大了17倍。但美国讲究的是精英政治。它关乎选择。它关乎开辟属于你自己的道路。我的意思是，这就是好莱坞的精髓。这就是加州的精髓。那是他们选择去生活的地方。
And that is antithetical. No matter how much the monarchy may modernize, it is antithetical to the idea of hereditary privilege, I think. And I think it inevitably gratesates it rubs up against it but the funny thing actually is that the harry and megan um imbroglio it clearly didn't affect the queen's popularity one job did it i mean by the end of the day she was absolutely colossally popular tom i mean the jubilee her speech we talked about that before, her speech when COVID hits, consciously looking back to the Second World War, the enormous success of the
这与世袭特权的理念是水火不容的。无论君主制如何现代化，它都与世袭特权的理念相悖，我认为。我认为它不可避免地会产生摩擦，会与之发生冲突。但有趣的是，哈里和梅根的风波显然一点也没有动摇女王的受欢迎程度，不是吗？我的意思是，到头来，她真的是极其受欢迎，汤姆。我是说，银禧庆典，她的演讲——我们之前谈过，当新冠疫情爆发时，她的演讲有意识地回溯到了第二次世界大战，
Platinum Jubilee. I mean, the funny thing with all these jubilees, and I've written about jubilees and royal occasions before, is that people always predict disaster and washout and public apathy. And that's never, ever vindicated that there's this enormous reservoir. And I think in the case of the Platinum Jubilee in particular, it's not just patriotic monarchism, but there was clearly an enormous reservoir of affection for somebody who basically, you know, she'd made that famous oath when she was 21 that she would serve the country. And in this extraordinary sort of self-abnegating performance, she had done that.
白金禧庆典的巨大成功。我的意思是，所有这些庆典都有个有趣的地方——我以前写过关于庆典和皇家盛事的文章——人们总是预测会有灾难、泡汤和公众的冷漠。但这种预测从来没有被证实过，人们心中总是有着巨大的喜爱之情。我认为特别是对于白金禧庆典而言，这不仅是爱国主义的君主主义，而且显然对这样一个人有着巨大的深情，她基本上——你知道的，她21岁时曾发下著名的誓言，承诺将为国家服务。以这种非凡的自我克制的表现，她做到了这一点。
What I found myself watching the news yesterday and what I have found from talking to family and friends is weirdly, and I feel ashamed of myself for this, because I know it's completely manipulative. And I know that it's being complicit in whatever film company it was that made Paddington. But the moment when I get the lump in the throat and have to wipe away a manly tear is when they show the footage that came from the Queen's recent jubilee where she is um having tea with paddington bear and he offers her a marmalade sandwich which she always keeps for emergencies and she opens her handbag and pulls out a marmalade sandwich and says that she does as well and and it's she gives this kind of seraphic smile and it's the sense that she's earned that smile i think over the decades and decades that she's you know lived in this gilded cage and she's in you know she's in a gilded cage she's in buckingham palace and all the people are outside and then the the um the opening of um
昨天我看新闻时发现，以及我与家人朋友交谈后的感受是，奇怪的是——为此我感到有点羞愧，因为我知道这完全是在操纵情绪。我知道这是在为制作帕丁顿熊的那家不知名的电影公司当帮凶。但当我喉头哽咽，不得不擦去一滴男子汉的眼泪时，那一刻正是他们播放女王最近庆典上的录像：她正与帕丁顿熊喝茶，帕丁顿熊递给她一个她总是留作紧急备用的橘子酱三明治，她打开手提包，拿出一个橘子酱三明治，说她也总是这样。她露出了那种天使般的微笑，我觉得那是她几十年来应得的微笑，你知道的，她生活在这个镀金的笼子里，她身处——你知道的，她身处镀金的笼子，她身处白金汉宫，而所有人都在外面，然后那个……
we will rock you starts kicking in outside and then she joins in and she starts to tap her teacup with her teaspoon and it's a bit you know this is as close as she gets to to what happened on ve day when she went out and joined the crowd and and she became part of us she became part of the people she became part of the crowd it's as close as she come and i found i find it incredibly moving and i think i think i'm not alone in finding that movie no not at all i completely agree with you tom the bit where paddington says thank you mom for everything i mean i found that moving even at the jubilee i found that very yeah lump in the throat and uh yeah and i found you know and also i i found so uh the last photos
外面开始响起《我们将震撼你》（We Will Rock You）的音乐，她也加入进来，用茶匙敲击茶杯，这有点像——这已经是她最接近当年的胜利日（VE Day）经历的时刻了，当时她走出去加入人群，成为了我们的一部分，成为了人民的一部分，成为了人群的一部分。这是她最接近的时刻了，我发现这令人难以置信地感人，我想我并不是唯一一个觉得感人的人。不，完全不是，我完全同意你的看法，汤姆。帕丁顿说“谢谢你，女士，为了这一切”那一段——我的意思是，即使在庆典上我也觉得很感人，我当时就觉得非常……嗯，喉头哽咽，而且——是的，我还发现，还有……最后几张照片
of her uh the last office she did was to receive Boris Johnson, who resigned and to receive his trust, the new prime minister, two days before she died. And she looks so frail, so ill in those photographs. And she's still carrying on. She's still doing it. She is living true to the coronation oath that she will serve right to her death. And she does. And I think that it kind of taps into the weirdness and the power of monarchy as a system of government, which is that a living person can become a symbol in a way that even presidents
关于她……她履行的最后职责是接见辞职的鲍里斯·约翰逊，并在她去世前两天接见新首相莉兹·特拉斯。在这些照片中，她看起来那么虚弱，那么生病。但她仍在坚持。她仍在继续。她真正践行了加冕誓言，要为国家服务到生命的最后一刻。她做到了。我认为这触及了君主制作为一种政府系统的独特性和力量：一个活生生的人可以变成一个象征，这是连总统都
can't. But Tom, you can see that as a mad, weird thing, that this person who is descended from Noah and from Woden is our head of state. But I think that you would have to be very... The madness and weirdness. Deaf. Very, very oblivious to the tug of history and the power of history. Not to feel some sense of the... There is a strange power to this that kind of short circuits everything rational. But Tom, the madness and weirdness lies in thinking that it's mad and weird.
做不到的。但汤姆，你可以认为这是一件疯狂而诡异的事情，这个源自诺亚和奥丁（Woden）后裔的人竟然是我们的国家元首。但我觉得你必须非常……这种疯狂与诡异。耳聋。对历史的牵绊和历史的力量极其极其无知，才会感受不到……这种形式中蕴含着一种奇特的力量，能够绕过一切理性。但汤姆，这种疯狂和诡异之处在于认为它疯狂和诡异。
I mean, most societies that have ever existed have been monarchies of some sort. I agree. Every constitution. But not just monarchies. So, you know, the ideals of the French Republic or the United States are similarly contingent, culturally determined.
我的意思是，有史以来绝大多数社会都是某种形式的君主制。我同意。每一种体制。但不仅仅是君主制。所以，你知道的，法兰西共和国或美国的理想同样是偶然的、由文化决定的。
Any American, whoever says to you, whoever says to you, oh, the monarchy, I don't agree with this principle, blah, blah, blah. And then in the next breath says the sanctity of the Oval Office, the president, the symbols matter. All our knowledge of history says that symbols matter, nations matter, a sense of- Well, I wouldn't say that. Human beings are not rational creatures.
任何一个对你说——任何对你说“哦，君主制，我不同意这种原则，巴拉巴拉”的美国人，紧接着又会说“椭圆形办公室的神圣性、总统、象征意义很重要”。我们对历史的所有认知都表明，象征意义很重要、国家很重要、一种对……嗯，我不会这么说。人类并非完全理性的生物。
I wouldn't say the nations inherently matter, but I would say that for nations to exist as kind of concepts that the people who live within them are prepared to accept, it is inherently a kind of a weird idea that we all belong to a kind of entity that has a kind of degree of sovereignty. I mean, these are quite culturally contingent ideas, and they are freighted with all kinds of history and assumptions that, if you pull the camera right back, are likely to look very odd. And I think that that is why there is always an oddness at the heart of how a nation represents itself and thinks of itself. And I think in that sense, a monarchy is as good a way of channeling that weirdness as any other. It's good if it works and it clearly does work. I mean, lots of people are invested in it and therefore to argue, if people are invested in it, that's what matters.
我不会说国家本质上有多么重要，但我想说的是，为了让国家作为一种概念存在，并得到生活在其中的人们的认同，我们都属于某种拥有一定程度主权的实体，这本身其实是一个相当奇怪的概念。我的意思是，这些都是高度文化偶然性的观念，它们承载着各种各样的历史和假设，如果把镜头拉远，它们看起来可能会非常古怪。我认为这就是为什么在国家自我表征和自我认知的核心，总是存在着一种怪异感。我认为从这个意义上说，君主制作为引导这种怪异感的方式，和其他任何方式一样好。如果它管用，那就是好方法，而且它显然管用。我的意思是，许多人都投入其中，因此可以说，如果人们为此投入了精力，那这才是最重要的。
Okay, but to play devil's advocate. Tom, now revealing his unpatriotic colors. No, I'm not. Monarchies work when the monarch is dutiful and as talented at serving the role that is ordained for her or for him obviously the prop you know as the application shows it's perfectly possible for to have terrible kings terrible queens yeah but i think another reason why people thank you for everything the paddington line why why people say that is the feeling that the queen has played her part brilliantly well you said tom didn't you that uh before we started recording
好吧，为了扮演魔鬼的代辩人。汤姆，现在暴露了他不爱国的一面。不，我没有。君主制之所以起作用，是因为君主是尽责的，并且擅长扮演为她或他注定要扮演的角色——显然，正如申请表所显示的，完全可能会出现糟糕的国王、糟糕的女王——是的，但我认为人们说出“谢谢你为这一切所做的一切”以及帕丁顿台词的另一个原因，是觉得女王完美地扮演了她的角色。你不是说过吗，汤姆，就在我们开始录音之前，
that you thought the queen, we were talking about how good a monarch the queen had been. And you said you thought there was a very good case that she had been given the options open to her and the possibilities that she had been the best monarch. I think so. She had fulfilled her duties more completely
你认为女王——我们当时在讨论女王作为君主是多么优秀。你说你认为很有理由认为，鉴于她所拥有的选择和可能性，她一直是最好的君主。我也这么认为。她比以往任何君主都更彻底地履行了职责，
than any monarch before her. Apart from Alfred, but he's not a king of England. Right. Are you still not counting Athelstan? Yeah, maybe Athelstan as well. I mean, to reiterate, the queen has to play her role as queen within the frameworks of the age as constituted. So she's not a Henry II or a or henry the eighth or henry the fifth
除了阿尔弗雷德大帝，但他不是英格兰国王。对。你还是不算埃塞尔斯坦吗？对，也许埃塞尔斯坦也算。我的意思是，重申一下，女王必须在既定时代的框架内扮演好女王的角色。所以她不是亨利二世、亨利八世或亨利五世，
or whatever but i think that to have died a much-loved symbol of her country but more than that a symbol that has evolved with her country and that has enabled her country to feel that it's it's still what it was even though it no no longer is. Yes. I think has been a remarkable achievement. And I think it's required incredible self-abnegation because I think she has had to repress her personality, the life she would have liked to have led for her whole life, pretty much, except perhaps briefly when she was in Malta.
诸如此类。但我觉得，能够作为一个备受爱戴的国家象征离世，更重要的是，一个与国家共同进化的象征，能够让国家觉得它依然保持着当年的模样，尽管它已经不再是那样了。是的。我认为这是一项非凡的成就。我认为这需要难以置信的自我克制，因为我认为她不得不压抑自己的个性，压抑她一生中本来想过的生活——大概除了在马耳他短暂的那段日子外，几乎一辈子都在压抑。
And I think that is a kind of heroic quality. Yeah. There's a wonderful uh George Orwell when he wrote about Englishness in the Blitz he talked about the sort of what makes a nation a nation he has a wonderful um passage where he says is there a kind of continuity you know what do you have in common with the child whose picture is on the mantelpiece who was once you everything has changed and yet somehow you're still the same and that that's sort of, that's true of countries, isn't it?
我认为这是一种英雄般的品质。是的。乔治·奥威尔在闪电战期间写到英国性时，有一段精彩的论述，他谈到了究竟是什么让一个国家成为一个国家。他有一段精彩的段落，他说，是否存在某种延续性？你知道的，你和壁炉架上那个曾经代表了一切、而一切都已改变却又不知何故依然如故的孩子有什么共同点？这就是国家的真实写照，不是吗？
And it's also true of the Queen herself. She did change. Her voice changed. She proved much more flexible than people often make allowances for. But she was still the same.
这也是女王本人的真实写照。她确实变了。她的声音变了。事实证明，她比人们通常认为的要灵活得多。但她依然是那个她。
You know, it's that great line from the leopard. For everything to stay the same, everything has to change. Yeah. And she was the perfect example of that.
你知道，那是《豹》里的名言：为了让一切保持不变，一切都必须改变。是的。而她就是这方面的完美典范。
Well, may she rest in peace. Agreed. So on to the new Tom, God Save the King. It'll be strange to get used to saying that, won't it? Yeah, it will. I actually sang it last night. That's good to know. But not in the privacy of your own home.
好吧，愿她安息。完全同意。那么接下来是新的汤姆，吾王万岁。习惯这么说会很奇怪，不是吗？是的，会的。我昨晚其实唱了这首歌。很高兴听到这个。但不是在你自己家的私密空间里吧。
No, no. I went to, there was a service. I was out and I saw that the service was on at um st bartholomew so i popped in for that and i think the service had been intended as one to pray for the queen and the rector very hurriedly had to change the script because she died about half an hour before the service was due to start and it ended with god save the king so i will always remember where i was yeah that's a wonderful moment on which to end and are you going to sing us out or will you will we be spared that pleasure you can spare that so an extraordinary
不，不。我去参加了一个礼拜活动。我当时在外面，看到圣巴塞tholomew教堂正在举行礼拜，所以我顺便进去了。那场礼拜原本是为女王祈祷的，牧师不得不非常仓促地修改稿子，因为她在礼拜开始前大约半小时去世了，最后以《吾王万岁》结束。所以我永远会记得我在哪里。是的，这是一个绝佳的结束时刻。你要为我们献唱一曲，还是说我们会免受这种折磨？你可以免去这个环节。所以，这是一段非凡的
sort of moment in history a nation in mourning we will be resuming normal restless history service of course um very soon uh but for the time being i think we should just simply say goodbye and uh thank you for everything. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
历史时刻，一个国家正在哀悼。我们当然很快就会恢复正常而不平静的历史播客服务；但目前，我想我们只需简单地说一声再见，谢谢你所做的一切。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。